Tim for difficulty of untangling the
operations and counterparty risks around
the world so what I'd like to know is
how his Treasury managed systemic risk
questions pose not just by Citigroup but
by all of the large companies but
potentially by Citigroup and
consultations with your regulatory
counterparts around the globe what are
you doing about that are we any safer
than we were a Europe there are
continuous conversations with financial
leaders around the world and I think you
you've seen them say that there's closer
coordination today and much better I'm
glad that there may be more coordination
let me ask it in the more specific
perhaps with Citi are you making any
effort to separate cities activities its
counterparty risks and operations around
the world that we say cause systemic
failure whereas systemic failure would
be caused if they failed are we making
any effort to segregate that safe from
their trading activity that's a fairly
high risk undertaking again as you know
we've made many statements and taken the
initiative to request major changes in
financial regulation in this country
which could address a number of those
issues for example assisting on capital
adequacy comprehensive oversight of
these institutions and very important a
resolution Authority so that no
institution and with the government
would not be in it putting it in a
position of having to take over an
institution or or to somehow support it
mr. assistant secretary yes I appreciate
the need for for reform of the financial
system and looking forward I think
that's exactly what we have to do the
question however is that we have a
system in place right now
Treasury came to the United States
Congress and said in October of 2008 we
have to have 700 billion dollars of the
economy will
one of the specific problems thing was
that city had this deeply intertwined
overseas operation that we were told as
a people would if we tried to unravel it
caused a systemic shutdown in in
economic markets that the results would
be catastrophic and that was one of the
principal reasons that the American
Congress went along with the tarp
bailout so my question is what are you
doing about that now what are you doing
to isolate the part of city and city's
operations that could cause systemic
failure if they go down from cities
other high-risk undertakings for example
their trading activities yeah well as
you know there is the Volcker rule
that's being discussed and and the
future you're talking about mr.
assistant secretary but we have to
survive day to day and it just Treasury
yeah who is responsible we don't want
you back here asking for money chair
warren we totally share your concerns
and that is why we are advocating that
perfomed be initiated and passed as
rapidly as possible I'm gonna do this
one more time
please do don't please don't tell me
about advocating change for the future
what I'd like to know is what are you
doing to manage the risks that are in
front of City and that face the American
people right now
well city again is under regulatory
oversight comprehensive regulatory
oversight and the regulator's are
responsible for assuring that city is
being properly controlled and that it
has adequate capital no efforts to
segregate the risky activities from the
systemically critical activities we are
not involved in managing city on a day
to day basis right
and the regulator's oversee Citigroup I
think that's a question you might ask
mr. Pandit when he comes here shortly
finish all right thank you I apologize
to my panelists were going over oh thank
you I just have a couple more questions
here one with respect there was an
interesting article by Reuters yesterday
about a small Midwestern bank called
Midwest Bank holdings this is a little
bit off topic but it'll get back to
topic in a second I just want to read it
here a small mid quote a small
Midwestern Bank has negotiated with the
US Treasury for taxpayers to essentially
buy the Bank shares at an above market
value price in an unusual transaction
reflecting how the government's bank
investments are entering a new phase
Midwest Bank Holdings agreed to swap
eighty four point eight million dollars
of preferred shares that sold to the US
government in 2008 for securities that
will convert to about only fifteen point
five million of common shares roughly an
eighty percent lost taxpayers and I
quotes a hedge fund managers there's a
lot of funny stuff going on here in
Section 101 of ISA it basically says
that the secretary shall take such steps
as may be necessary to prevent unjust
enrichment of financial institutions
participating in a program including by
preventing the sale of a troubled asset
to the secretary at a higher price than
what the seller paid to purchase the
asset so I was wondering if you have any
if you can elucidate us with respect to
this particular transaction and does
this pretend a change with respect to
Treasury's view of the assets that holds
under tarp and as a remaining sum as we
looked at the situation of Midwest Bank
we determined that the best way to
protect the taxpayers investment would
be to convert our our position in to
mandatory convertible preferred on the
condition that that Bank raise
additional capital a substantial amount
of additional capital from public
sources so this is all about protecting
the taxpayer
interests and preventing we hope further
erosion
in our position with that thing okay so
again I mean I I know you saw that you
can't really speculate with respect to
the city bank and again we have huge
interest in that particular company and
the huge number of shares are
outstanding so you might consider other
sorts of situations like this that might
convert what we currently hold into
other sorts of security interests in the
company
well our interests are protecting
taxpayers and their investments and
there may be situations where we will
look at what we might do in the way of
protecting ourselves through a
structured recapitalisation that we
might participate in but in each one of
these cases we're guided by what's in
the taxpayers interest okay so that gets
me back to some of the other things that
the administration is doing and whether
or not that's really in the best
interests of the taxpayer and
shareholders in this case a Citibank and
you mentioned the Volcker Rule a
so-called
which I guess I saw on a report that
formal language was sent up to the hill
today what effect will that have on my
interest as a taxpayer in the Citibank
as a shareholder there was a reluctant
shareholder at that to the profitability
of Citibank into its businesses again I
think that's a question better asked to
the CEO of Citigroup and again I cannot
comment on potential impacts on the
company in which we hold a large
investment okay well it seems to me that
the government's giving one hand and
taking with another and including now
the respective resolution authority that
you're talking about the administration
and you note this in your testimony that
quote the administration's proposals
provide this resolution Authority
subject to strict governance and control
procedures with losses absorbed not by
taxpayers but by equity holders
unsecured treasurer's but unsecured
creditors and if necessary through a fee
on other major finance
to shion's similar to the financial
crisis responsibility feet so first of
all aren't proposals like these actually
putting additional costs and burdens on
banks at a time when ensuring that banks
are sufficiently capitalized should be
Priority One well we think that these
measures are called for given the these
circumstances that the taxpayers have
faced we by the way we intend this
Treasury secretary has announced to get
back every penny that we have invested
through tarp and the financial crisis
recovery fee is one way of doing that we
would also point out that many of these
institutions have paid very large
bonuses and they can afford and we think
to reimburse the taxpayer well
unfortunately you know they also have to
run a business as well but anyway pull
my time is up we'll get into that later
thank you Thank You mr. Adkins mr.
silvers it might be helpful mr.
assistant secretary to try to clarify
what the taxpayers interest is here in
light of my colleagues questioning first
let me return may be a painful subject
do you agree that Citigroup today is a
systemically significant institution
again mr. silvers with all respect we
cannot comment on a judgment about
whether they're systemically significant
but you agree that they were systemic ly
significant in fall of 2008 though the
determination was made at that time that
that they were systemic ly significant
knew your written testimony appears
you're not going to answer that question
frontally I'm going to infer it from
your written testimony that you believe
that if you wish to tell me that you
don't that's fine
but let's let's start with that it would
appear to me that the United States as
has been frequently noted it's a 27
percent common stock holder in Citigroup
and that that's a significant financial
interest of the public at this point and
I assume you agree with that I do it
would also appear that there is at least
a significant
probability based on historical events
that we are some sort of guarantor of
citigroup's obligations in light of the
I think what we agree that that we did
not allow Citigroup to default on those
obligations on multiple times in the
past and most recently a year or so ago
you're free to disagree with me I don't
expect you to confirm what I just said
well we did guarantee part of their
assets for a period of time and we were
well compensated for doing that right
I'm suggesting that we have a more
broader somewhat ill-defined guarantee
certainly the the certainly the credit
markets or at least credit market
analysts believe that to be the case so
we're not in the position as my
colleague would appear to suggest it
seems to me of being simply a
stockholder in Citigroup and then
finally if we believe that there is at
least the possibility that Citigroup
will turn out to be systemic ly
significant today as it was in 2008
there's an even larger interest in play
at play here would you disagree that
that's at least the possibility that
there is a a systemic interest here that
the taxpayer has well first of all let
me say again that the purpose of the
regulatory reform initiative is to
assure that no institution could infer
or the public can infer that there's
some type of implicit guarantee of a
financial institution by the US
government we want to remove that that
possible commented on that unfortunately
I think we weren't I agree unfortunately
this perform is not passed and today we
live in a in a reformist world yes and I
gather at least one of my colleagues
would prefer to keep it that way that we
live in a reformed 'less world but but
that's how we you know you Georgia has
to function in that in that arena it
seems like the public has three
interests in play at Citi my question to
you is what what is the how would how
how does Treasury balance or manage what
strategy does Treasury pursuing the
light of these three somewhat
conflicting interests well again our
strategy as a shareholder in Citigroup
is first of all to dispose of our
investment as rapidly as we
in a responsible way secondly not to get
involved in the management of the
company we don't believe that's in the
shareholders interests or in Treasury's
interest we are casting our involvement
very narrowly as a voting shareholder
and voting only on certain items in a
proxy statement so we think that the
best thing we can do to fold one exit
that investment as rapidly as we
responsibly can and secondly push hard
for financial reform let me say it again
to make sure that the US taxpayer is
never again put in a situation like we
face today with Citigroup with only 27%
of that company can I turn to a
different matter than as my time is
about to run out
I alluded in my opening statement to the
fact that common stockholders of
Citigroup have been over time diluted
and largely as a result of actions taken
by this administration over the last 12
months
although not exclusively there was a
little bit of dilution involved in the
initial suspect transaction however it
appears to me that there's substantial
differences nonetheless between AIG the
the other what I find to be the
inevitable comparison in terms of a
systemically significant failing
institution the dilution they are in the
dilution and Citigroup and I would like
to ask you to prepare to provide us with
your analysis of the comparative of
comparing the dilution in the two areas
and in particular your analysis of the
effect of the difference between what
happened in AIG where the Treasury came
in with with cret with debt debt
financing entirely senior to the common
stockholders and then took a large
Commons position through warrants and
that and the city situation in which
preferred stock holders were converted
into common and thus essentially more
cash was put in pari passu with the
common obviously I'm not asking you to
answer that question now but I'd like
I'd like a apples to apples comparison
of the dialouge in' and the two firms as
of two
well first of all a IG received
assistance in the fall of 2008 the
Federal Reserve actually made the bulk
of that investment and the Federal
Reserve owns preferred shares voting
shares that control about 80 percent of
the voting rights is my understanding
and the end City on the other hand we
made these preferred investments in City
as you well know and we had an exchange
last summer as part of a number of
exchanges have preferred for common that
we're done at the time to bolster cities
tangible common equity ratio so gonna
stop you there for Allison yeah we will
come back to this and will permit um
we'll keep the record open okay we can
add more detailing in this all right
thank you I just want to be disciplined
about time mr. McWatters Thank You mr.
assistant secretary during calendar year
2009 did tarp recipients sell any
mortgage-backed securities to either the
Fed the Treasury or Fannie or Freddie I
don't have an exact answer for that mr.
McCotter so they have to get it for you
if you'd look into that and also look
into survey price that was paid a fair
market value at the time or was it par
something in excess of fair market value
is is what I'm interested in knowing
okay what actions has City taken again
specifically to negate the
too-big-to-fail problem so we're not
having this discussion again in five
years well may I respectfully ask that
you pose that question to mr. Panthers
it was the CEO I think he said a better
position than I to describe the action
as they've taken internally I know but I
suspect that you talked with him on
occasion you actually I have not talked
to mr. Pandit about this matter no okay
how did city employ the 45 billion
dollars of taxpayer funds they that
those those funds were for general
corporate purposes they were part of the
capital
of Citigroup it was designed that per
entire program was designed to provide
additional capital to banks okay the
city uses retail or commercial bank
deposits to finance proprietary trading
activity again I'd ask you to ask that
question was depended I don't have that
information but I mean this has been
alleged as one of the causes of the
financial crisis and so it's it's not a
question you've asked no it's not okay
okay do you have a view as to how the
activity of short sellers in the last
quarter of 2008 affected the financial
crisis and affected Citigroup I don't
have that information sir okay yeah any
views as to how the mark-to-market
accounting rules particularly how they
were revised in April of 2009 affected
city groups financial reporting again I
think you'd have to ask the CEO so these
these these are questions you've just
not thought about or not even though
that these are not obscure questions
about short sellers in mark-to-market
nothing like the role of my area and
Treasury is to manage the taxpayers
investments and to retrieve those
investments as rapidly as we responsibly
can okay I can anticipate the response
to this question it has been alleged
that Goldman Sachs among others sold
collateralized debt obligations to
investors while at the same time betting
against or selling short those same
securities are you aware that City is
engaged in any of that activity I'm not
okay okay what is your view about the
effect the implicit guarantee from the
taxpayers has had on the competitors of
Citigroup
well let me say again there is no
guarantee today of Citigroup or any part
of
grew up on the part of the US government
oh I said implicit guarantee not
explicit well I'm not sure I can comment
and what implicit guarantee me and so
I'm trying to be as precise as I can
okay fair enough but so as far as you
know it has had no effect on competitors
that I mean well let me ask it this way
is is city today too big to fail I mean
the answer is no you can fail and be
liquidated then I would say it would
have no effect on competitors but I mean
your city too big to fail today again I
I said testified and as I've said before
I can't comment on the condition of
Citigroup
as a as since the US Treasury is a major
holder of their shares okay my time is
nearing the end so I will stop there
thank you mister McWaters superintendent
Hayman thank you
i intend to ask mr. pan that about their
progress in preventing foreclosures i'm
gonna be particularly interested in
their modification process and
particularly around conversions from
trial mods to conversions and i think
this is more than just a process
question i think some people tend to
forget that the reason we are in this
financial crisis is because of the
foreclosure crisis and until we solve
the housing and foreclosure crisis we
will never be sure of financial
stability so I think it is an important
part of this hearing and an important
part of the tarp program can you share
with me your assessment of city's
performance under the HAMP program yes
sir
like other banks we think they got off
to a pretty slow start they've picked up
speed actually City has today offered
trial mods or made final modifications
to about 60 percent of the eligible
mortgages in his portfolio which I
believe ranks at number one in terms of
their progress nonetheless they still
have a long way to go
and we are actively involved with City
and the other major banks which
the bulk of these mortgages to make sure
that they are reviewing those portfolios
identifying eligible homeowners and
offering them modifications and final
modifications as soon as possible I
should also point out that today they're
about 1.7 million people we estimate who
are eligible for modifications under the
HAMP program and the servicers have
extended offers to about 1.3 million
there are over 1 million trial
modifications in place today that are
saving homeowners about over $500 so
thank you for raising that because due
to the Treasury's extension of that
three-month period by which borrowers
have to make payments before they are
converted from a trial mod to a to a
permit amount that extension expired at
the end of January so we are anxiously
all awaiting the the numbers that could
even approach a half a million
individuals who we are awaiting how they
were the the denial whether they were
offered a permit or not mod were they if
they were denied what is the result of
that appeal process can you any
expectations of what we may hear from
city and I certainly intend to ask City
and if you can't answer that can you
give us some idea and we expect that
this data will come out in the next week
or so if you can give us some idea of
what our expectations may be with
respect to that data well again we're
looking forward to the release of the
monthly data for January
I'm sorry February and there is progress
being made in decisioning the trial
modifications considerable progress and
this will be taking place in the weeks
to come as well and also there are
rights for homeowners who are denied to
appeal their denials as well so we've
tried to make this program as simple
today as transparent as possible we have
been working very closely with the
leading servicers especially to assure
that they
moving as expeditiously as they can and
they have the resources also to make
decisions as rapidly as possible we know
these homeowners are waiting in the
meantime though they're still saving an
average of over $500 a month and we are
to the extent that they are denied a
permanent or gauge conversion there's a
question of whether they would have been
better off pursuing another alternative
whether short sale and look to rent as
opposed to staying in a trial
modification of four or five three four
or five six months I do want to because
in recognition of the the challenges in
conversion and those low conversion
rates you have announced a new system
going in January June 1 that will now
require documentation upfront and I I
think there's certain benefits to that
but do we run a risk of shifting the
problem yes we will have higher
conversions but will we have fewer
people entering the process unless we
really modify those documentation I
think that's a good question it's one
we've been concerned about as well and
that's why we've tried to simplify the
documentation requirements and also we
provide the documents that a homeowner
may need on our website as well as
voluminous information about how to
apply how to go through the process how
to make appeals now March 1 was the date
I think we were previously given about
having that web portal up and running so
borrowers can identify can you give me
an update on the status of expanding
that I think we were told earlier that
they're going to be over 100 servicers
participating by March 1 yeah that way I
don't have the exact number of services
that are participating but that product
that program has been moving ahead very
rapidly and will continue to make
enhancements to that website going
forward and I would also point out we've
had millions of people access the
website so and and also let me mention
we're working closely with counselors
around the country and in holding events
throughout the country to bring people
in who may be eligible for this program
and help them have their mortgages
modified as rapidly as well we look
forward to the the reports and in your
efforts of transparency understanding
and clearly how those
we're treated thank you thank you thank
you mr. assistant secretary I have one
last question on behalf of the entire
panel and that is are you saying today
that no one in Treasury monitors the
financial condition of city and that no
one in Treasury is trying to manage the
systemic risk that city poses or are you
saying that that's just not your job we
do look at obviously public information
about Citigroup but you don't have any
private conversations with City I
personally I think that there have been
conversations with Citigroup over time I
myself have not had conversations with
Citigroup management about the condition
of the company and with the CEO about
that subject so are you telling me that
was my question yeah
that no one in Treasury is
systematically observing and monitoring
the audition there are there city does
visit with us from time to time and
provide updates on their situation so
I'm still trying to understand yes so
that means we just had the wrong witness
here today there were other people in
within Treasury who are engaged in these
jobs it's just not your job I
participated in briefings in the past on
city groups
situation we do have conversations with
Citigroup about their their situation
yes that is true all right I appreciate
it Thank You mr. assistant secretary I
invite you to stay for the next panel
thank you very much hear from mr. Pandit
thank you thank you the witness is
excused mr. Pandit
thank you
mr. Pandit gentlemen if you could excuse
us mr. Pandit thank you for coming today
the chair recognizes you for five
minutes if you'd like to make an opening
statement I'd ask you to hold it to five
minutes of we will put your written
statement in the record whatever its
length mr. Pandit please
three seconds gone okay
Thank You chair Warren and members of
the panel thank you for inviting me here
Citigroup today is a fundamentally
different company from what we inherited
two years ago Citigroup is now operating
on a very strong foundation to generate
sustained profitability for the benefit
of all our stakeholders for us as for
many other institutions the bridge to
the other side to sound footing came
from the American people and I want to
thank our country for providing city
with tarp funding last year we repay
twenty billion dollars of tarp
investment in addition we paid the
government three billion dollars on as
dividends and another 5.3 billion in
premiums on the asset guarantee program
that we have now exited taxpayer still
hold 27% of city's common stock and we
look forward to helping them make money
on that investment city owes a large
debt of gratitude to the American
taxpayers we have renewed our financial
strength we have overall risk management
reduced our risk exposures defined a
clear strategy and we've made city a
more focused enterprise at the end of
2009 we are one of the best capitalized
banks in the world with the Tier one
ratio of eleven point seven percent it
care one common ratio of nine point six
percent and thirty six billion dollars
or reserves our leverage is twelve to
one down from eighteen to one when I
became CEO we'd cut the size of our
balance sheet by 21 percent from its
peak by half a trillion dollars and our
riskiest assets have been substantially
reduced cities casualty
quiddity is now a strong hundred and
ninety-three billion dollars and we have
reduced our operating costs by more than
13 billion dollars per year perhaps the
most important strategic action we've
taken is to mandate a return to basics
return to banking as the core of our
business and as a result we've sold more
than 30 businesses and substantially
scaled back proprietary trading city is
a better Bank today but for City being
better is not good enough our customers
and America's taxpayers need a different
roadmap first a lot still needs to be
done to promote economic recovery
particularly in the housing area since
2007 city has held eight hundred and
twenty-four thousand families in their
efforts to avoid foreclosure total loss
mitigation solutions increased by fifty
percent versus two thousand eight and we
remain number one in active HAMP
modifications in 2009 City originated
eighty billion of mortgages and provided
eighty billion of credit card lending
and in addition our company used tarp
funds specifically to support new
lending to individuals to families to
communities and businesses taxpayers
have a right to know how we put that
money to use and we were the only bank
to publish regular reports on the use of
tarp capital second city supports reform
of the financial regulatory system
America and our trading partners need
smart common-sense regulation to reduce
the risk of bank failures mortgage
foreclosures lost GDP and taxpayer
bailouts
I know these are issues that are being
debated right now but let me share with
you three areas I think are important
first financial institution reform let's
address too big to fail once and for all
through the creation of a systemic risk
regulator
and a resolution authority by making
sure banks are banks focused on clients
second market reforms let's level the
playing field with common standards
across the entire financial sector let's
create transparency particularly in the
derivatives markets with the use of
standardization and clearing houses and
third consumer reforms we support the
need for a strong consumer authority
that is part of the regulatory system to
promote greater transparency sound
practices growth and stability in the
consumer credit market banks and
non-banks need to be more responsible
these are reforms that could be costly
for the industry but City believes they
are necessary Thank You chair Warren
members of the panel for this
opportunity to review city's progress
thank you very much mr. Pandit again we
appreciate your being here today I'd
like to start with a a little quote from
the emergency economic stabilization Act
or tarps we've all come to know it where
Treasury is to assure that its authority
is quote used in a manner that protects
home values college funds retirement
accounts and life savings and preserves
home ownership and promotes jobs and
economic growth that was that was
Congress's statement about why tarp was
done and what Treasury is authorized to
use money to advance those specific
goals in a June 22nd 2009 Reuters
article you're quoted as saying we will
be playing the to growth themes very
clearly one is globalization and the
other is growth in emerging markets
Wilbur Ross this morning referred to
Citi as essentially a foreign bank so
the question is why should the US
taxpayer alone carry city madam chair
we're not a foreign bank we're a global
bank
we're actually America's
Banke we started in business years ago
helping America's businesses export
their products and that's what we've
been doing in this particular time as we
need growth as we need jobs it's even
more important that we help small
businesses medium businesses and large
businesses make those exports as we do
that we need operations on the ground
and in many of these operations we raise
deposits to help large companies in the
u.s. get loans on the ground they need
and as well some of those deposits help
us facilitate loans in the US market
well but you describe your growth as
globalization and growth in emerging
markets it sounds like these are your
words about where you plan to expand
your activities we are completely
focused on making sure that we continue
our lending to US customers make sure
we're helping our clients our customers
through the issues they're facing now
it's also very clear that our clients
are coming to us small clients middle
sized clients large clients they want to
tap foreign consumer basis the growth is
coming from the foreign consumer they
believe that's how they will grow that's
how they create jobs and that's what I
meant we want to make sure we support
the businesses in America get to the
other side well good so let me get some
data then on what's happening how much
does City lend to US enterprises for US
operations our total loans outstanding
for all the US businesses about 450
billion dollars can I shrink that up
it's not all US businesses the question
I at least wanted to ask about is u.s.
enterprises for us operations jobs in
America I think the number is 450
billion dollars lent in the u.s. can you
divide that into how much do you lend to
businesses that don't have any foreign
operations madam chair I can't do that
but I can get back to you okay that's
fair so can I ask one other though about
just the lending that you do what
lending and other transactions has city
participated
and involving the government of Greece
we do business with a lot of sovereign
countries who need our global expertise
including coming to the US markets and
so I know we've been doing business with
Greece but I don't have the details with
me do you know how much debt the
government of Greece debt from the
government of Greece that city holds I
don't know the exact number by know it's
not a large amount not a meaningful
amount in our entire opera okay not a
meaningful amount yes okay good that's
that's fun mr. Atkins a thank you ma'am
cheer up thank you very much mr. Pandit
for being here today it's a pleasure to
have you take time out from your busy
schedule to be here I ask this of
assistant secretary Allison last time
but so I want to explore it with you and
this has to do with the the offering
back in December it seems that the
timing and experience of that particular
offering is something that we'd not like
to repeat and obviously the taxpayer now
is the largest single shareholder of
Citibank so as an executive with a
background in equity markets and
experience with the capital markets I
was wondering if you could share with us
your reflections on how the Treasury
Department should think about monetizing
its position in Citibank common stock
going forward here mr. Atkins of course
that's cities I mean that's the
Treasury's decision in terms of how they
want to do it we do know that they'll be
able to sell stock after March 16th and
they've announced publicly they do want
to sell stock over the next 12 months or
so and there are lots of different
methodologies of doing it right from
selling it in the market every day but
also we believe there's substantial
demand for this stock it is not a secret
that the government wants to sell it's
not a secret that the stock price in the
markets today are reflecting the fact
they're a seller in a large amount and
that we believe there are investors here
in the US who are getting ready for that
offering as to how they do it when they
do it with whom they do it those
all the Treasury's decisions well when
you look back at the offering in
December then you know clearly it was a
primary offering and then trying to be
coordinated with a potential large
secondary offering there by the
government so as far as the interests
that goes in the marketplace was there a
large cover ratio for that offering at
the time or what exactly was the problem
that we saw in December miss Adkins that
was the largest common stock offering
ever done in the US and particularly
when you consider that as the percentage
of city's common stock outstanding it
was extremely large and don't forget
that was done in the face off the market
knowing the government was going to sell
its 27% in not-too-distant future so
they had a choice do I buy now do I buy
later those were all the backgrounds
that was late in the year in doing that
offering and by the way when we did that
offering unfortunately how the bank
decided they wanted to do a large
offering right in the middle of what we
were doing but we got it done and we got
it done as the largest offering and we
were able to pay back the taxpayers and
we were able to exit the guarantee
program I consider that to be success
okay
well then now looking forward to you
have a stock prices about three dollars
a share or so which of course puts it in
a special zone as far as some
institutions and the way the market
views it what do you all have as far as
plans to address that price of the stock
in relation to the huge amount I me you
are that now the thus I guess has have
the largest number of shares outstanding
of any New York Stock Exchange listed
company and therefore we're also the
most traded stock on many days in the
New York Stock Exchange by the way the
stock last I came and was three dollars
forty four cents okay sorry and so I
think at the end of the day stock prices
are important but what's really
important is performance what do you
earn sustain profitability which is
really what I'm focused on my biggest
job is to make sure we make money on a
sustained basis and therefore help the
government make money well in your in
your testimony you mentioned that you've
sold on
city holdings after having restructured
your firm viewing this is the non core
businesses I'm about thirty some-odd
businesses in your 10k I think it said
more than 20 so I was wondering what you
how did you all decide as far as you
know what is core versus what's not core
and that was job number one for me
coming into city looking at the
businesses trying to figure out what
business are we in what clients do we
serve what are we good at and you put
all those things together it turned out
at the end of the day we are a great
Bank that is basically in the business
of helping people manage their accounts
providing them loans providing them
capital providing them investment
services and it became very clear that
we were in a lot of businesses that were
not directly related to being a bank and
so the fundamental decision that I made
is that we're gonna be back we're gonna
be the global bank for America's
companies serving them here but also
wherever they want to go but not only
for companies but the same capability
should be available to individuals as
well so that's the decision we made and
on the basis of that it became very
clear what was not core it was a large
part of the company and that's what I've
been selling very systematically over
the last two years see my time is up
thank you mr. silvers yes I thank you
sure again mr. Pandit I want to commend
you for being here and especially my
appreciation both for your presence in
your testimony you said a moment ago
that in trying to focus on on what
Citigroup is good at that you viewed
sort of a return to core banking is the
primary direction you were headed and
you mentioned some numbers about loans I
have here the report I'm sure you're
familiar with from Standard & Poor's
from last month that shows and the
numbers don't match so I wondered if you
could explain it to me that shows that
commercial and corporate law
a by citigroup have fallen dramatically
over the last two years that from a
level of according to SNP two hundred
and six billion dollars in at the year
year in two thousand seven two hundred
and twenty seven billion dollars today
our end of third quarter
I believe 2009 I don't think they had
the fourth quarter numbers at that time
in view of the my understanding that
your divestitures have largely been
unrelated to commercial loans can you
explain to me what's happening here
sure mr. Silver's we when we decided
what was core what's not mm-hmm there
were also assets that were part of what
was not core to us as well those are
there were either clients that we
shouldn't be serving but they didn't
need us more they were businesses that
were not core to us they were assets
that were gathered through core
businesses and so those numbers reflect
selling businesses that are not core to
us selling assets that were not core to
us taking any marks on assets that well
under mr. I don't understand how you can
reconcile that type of that the scale of
that retreat from business lending which
is after all in my view just absolutely
central to whether or not tarp is
succeeding the scale of that retreat
from business lending with your
characterization of very focusing on
core banking because I look at other
numbers I don't see that type of retreat
from from other types of activity other
than obviously things that you're
totally divesting from let me assure you
we will make any good loan that we see
to a client the regulator's want us to
make prudent loans we are doing that
some of those were leveraged loans there
are part of practices that we shouldn't
have been part of they're not core to
the banking mission so it's very easy to
look at those numbers and think that
they actually represent our lending
appetite or our appetite to serve client
but that isn't so that reflects the
narrowing and focusing of our business
as to what we should be as a bank I want
a second question about
this type of issue in the area of
commercial real estate which has been a
concern of this panel again my survey of
the the data suggests a kind of flat
line in terms of the the total assets in
commercial real estate in this in the in
the court at the holding company level
portfolio of around seventy five eighty
billion dollars my question about that
is is that I wondered how's that have
you taken any write downs in commercial
real estate and now how do I understand
this this flat level in the count and
and are we are right towns coming number
of things one a lot of that portfolio is
marked market we have taken right downs
much of that portfolio is community
lending and that's money good as well
there are some accrual loans that we've
made and those loans are well reserved
against let me also say that most of our
loans are for office buildings against
leases and some of the major
metropolitan areas so that's the very
well scrubbed over portfolio I'll make
one more point on this which is that
that's less of an issue for city mm-hmm
can I try then turn to another question
about your core strategy and I think
with Hamilton expire as I understand it
correct me if I'm wrong you've been
telling the world that that you are
going to be focused in addition to what
might be described as really
old-fashioned banking in two other areas
that you're going to continue to have a
significant capital markets desk with a
broad exposure to global markets
derivatives currencies and the like and
that you're going to be continuing to
put focus on your global transaction
services business which has been the
only the sort of consistent profit
driver over the last year do I am I am I
reading back to you correctly that's
correct okay we've heard I think a fair
amount about the extent to which the GTS
business makes the city particularly
systemically significant it's my
understanding from press accounts that
this was a core arguments that he made
to the government during November of
2008 that that that city could not be
allowed to fail because of the
importance of that
business - the global capital markets my
question to you is can you justify
having that business connected to the
type of capital markets desk you intend
to keep connecting it to in light of the
what appears to be taking something so
systemically important and then tying it
to something so Bella tively risky so
let me start by saying I don't recall
making that statement to anybody nor
does any nor do I recall anybody who
directly works for me
making that stage well which statements
are the statement you said about sorry
about the the fact that this was the
argument we made to the government about
systemic safe oh oh okay well then let
me ask you this would you commit here
that as long as you're at Citigroup that
you will not come to the government in
the future and make the argument that
the GTS business requires being bailed
out should your other businesses go
south yes let me commend you for giving
me a straight answer it's a rare
experience in my role but I think that's
why we're here for straight answers I
wanted you to hear from me what we're
doing at Citi and why we're doing the
right things both but but also for if my
shareholder but if my colleagues will
indulge me please explain nonetheless
how those two businesses are compatible
in your view let me explain this to you
we do business for Coke and Pepsi
they are Coke is in 250 countries around
the world they need to manage their
operations we do everything for them
from cash management do custody -
clearing settling for them they need
foreign exchange management they need
liability management they need interest
rate management so we have to have those
operations to serve them in that
particular way the fundamental shift
that I made was to make sure that our
trading operations and our cash
management operations and all our
banking operations are geared towards
doing those things that our clients need
and by the way if you do that correctly
having been in the business for as long
as I have those are the kind of
businesses that generate good value for
clients without creating the risk that
has been created in the system
historically my time is way over thank
you
oh my goodness thank you I apologize mr.
McWaters thank you and thank you mr.
pennant for appearing today appreciate
it very much
do you have any reason to anticipate
that Citigroup will need additional tarp
funds no great on a fair market value
basis after considering contingent
liabilities is Citigroup solvent yes are
any material divisions or subsidiaries
of Citigroup insolvent no let me be very
clear we look at the entire company
under Citigroup and what matters is that
we're well capitalized we have the
reserves we have the liquidity and by
the way we stress ourselves very often
to make sure that's always the case okay
speaking of stressing if the stress
tests were conducted again today under
current economic conditions would
Citigroup be required to raise
additional capital and there so how much
do you think no no could you tell us why
specifically Citigroup needed a tarp
funded bailout what happened what went
wrong
mr. mcquarters we came into this market
city came into this market with assets
on which it took substantial losses in
2008
now we address that by raising 48
billion dollars of capital in the market
in early 2008 we sold another set of
businesses raised 10 billion of capital
and we got 25 billion dollars from the
government in the first tarp round and
the result of all of that was we had
10.7% Tier one and at the same time we
had reduced our assets we had reduced
risk fundamentally we were in the right
place and in any rational market that
would be a solid balance sheet for the
future but we were not in a rational
market post Lehman Brothers close to
Laconia
break up the capital markets froze there
was a journal sense of
turn about where the economies might go
where unemployment might go and and
different stocks of different bank
started reacting to that our stock
started going down in late 2008 and so
on that Friday in late November our
stock was at three dollars 37 cents now
in a market of that sort unfortunately
sometimes stock prices can have an
impact on conference on all sorts of
stakeholders that are out there and
rather than taking the risk as we talk
to the Federal Reserve s talk as we talk
to the Treasury the view was let's take
that issue off the table that's what
happened okay what actions have you
taken to negate your status is too big
to fail I mean how can can we get to a
point realistically where if this
happens again City is simply broken up
sold off or recapitalized by the private
sector without government intervention
we have taken number steps mister
mcquarters - first of all it starts with
capital we have a very strong capital
base very strong liquid a very strong
reserves that's the starting point on
this the second part is create earnings
which is why we took thirteen billion
dollars of cost out of there the third
part of that is change your risk profile
and we've done that now we still have
some legacy assets so you came in with a
group of assets into this environment
but we have changed that as well we
managed our regional businesses on the
basis off cash on the ground liquidity
on the ground we work with our global
regulators so we made significant
changes in the financial health of the
company we've made significant changes
in the risk management of the company
but we've also targeted the company
towards those businesses that helped
clients and really don't Nestle create
the risk that has been created in the
past but let me also say I do think we
need regulation which is why I said why
I said in my opening statement let's get
to that resolution authority so that
this never happens again
okay one more quick question you are a
vet
of the capital purchase program what
advice can you give for how that program
can be improved it's ongoing I mean I
mean there's money out the door not
every institution has repaid tarp funds
how can it be improved the tarp funds
were from what I understand put in place
a lot of the reason was to inject
capital into the banks not only so they
could lend and they could do the right
things for the American people but it
was to create a sense of confidence so
we took the confidence in the financial
system off the table that was the point
on that for those people who still have
tarp funds I don't have any other advice
but to say that step in and make sure
that you manage your business to take
the cost out that you need to manage it
as efficiently as possible and start
creating a story and a business model
that can translate into earnings because
that's the best way in which the capital
markets can give you equity which you
can then use to repay the government
okay thank you thank you mister McWaters
superintendent Hayman thank you if you
were here and I believe you were in the
back when I was questioning mr. Allison
I highlighted that the mortgage crisis
really gave rise to the financial crisis
and and for that reason I was very
pleased to see in your written testimony
as well as in your oral testimony you
referenced your efforts toward
foreclosure mitigation and in your
written testimony highlighted the the
fact that city has the highest
percentage of eligible loans in and in
active modification mortgage
modifications at 50% trial and permanent
as a percentage of eligible mortgages
and and though you can be applauded for
that outreach effort I think a more
important metric is is the actual
conversion of trial mods tooken to to
permanent sustainable mortgages I
believe the last report from Treasury
has
a hundred and ten thousand of mortgages
that are in active trial mods with the
extension of Treasury through January 31
we are now awaiting results from all
institutions but I think anxiously
awaiting your results as well as to how
those individuals were treated and I
think the important part is these are
individuals who have been willing and
able to make these reduced payments and
are awaiting final determination we know
that there have been problems that
servicers we know there are our problems
in the appeal process so can you give us
any information about what we may expect
to see in the the the decisioning with
respect to those trial mods mr. neimand
I completely agree with you that
attacking the issue of housing is
important for the economy but
particularly for our customers our
clients as well
we as the assistant secretary said we're
number one and active have modifications
right now thank you stated sixty percent
as the number right now the ratio of
completion is about eighteen percent
right that we think that number is going
to go up to forty percent maybe pretty
soon that's where we think it's going to
go and not everybody who's gotten into
that program is initially going to
qualify because they may not have the
documentation they may not have the
information that's necessary to do that
which is why what we've done is we've
created a city modification plan on the
other side if you don't qualify and you
don't meet every standard we still have
modification programs and plans
available for these people who are going
through this particular change
do you see documentation because this
has been an issue I've heard from other
servicers partly it's I think it's a
we've heard concerns on the resources
and processes the servicers losing
documentation we've heard is instances
of borrowers reluctant or producing a
wrong documentation but I'm also very
concerned that the Treasury has not
given enough discretion to servicers and
lenders to make those decisions have you
found that or would make any
recommendations and changes in the
Hampden tation process let me say by the
way the Treasury already has made
changes and they're all positive changes
and these are the kind of changes
I think are going to have a positive
impact on modifications as well let me
also say we have 4,000 people that are
doing this for us
I've hired 1400 people in last year to
make sure we can help people get through
these documentation issues these are
case-by-case issues do you in your
modification process are you utilizing
principal reductions and would you could
you